Our project is centered around
these experimental design chalk
talks that we've incorporated
in our introductory molecular
biology class for
graduate students
at Harvard Medical School.
And we've looked at the
effect of these chalk
talks in a few
different ways, both
looking at video
recordings of students
in their first and second
times doing these chalk
talks during the
course, as well as
written answers to
experimental design questions
throughout the course.
We've also been
looking at and thinking
about how this affects students
confidence or self-efficacy
with the skills or
science communication
and experimental design and how
that changes from the beginning
to the end of the semester.
We've also been
developing some resources
for training students.
Training students in how
to do experimental design
in chalk talks.
So a chalk talk is literally
talking with chalk.
And so what it is, it's
very different from a type
of presentation that we
see a lot with our trainees
is that we do a good job of
teaching presentations using
PowerPoint in the background.
But in this case, they don't
have PowerPoint, right?
So they actually have to
do an unscripted talk.
Well, they're scripted.
But they do it in an
unstructured way at the board.
And they walk through an
experimental protocol.
What's different
and what you see
with that presentation
in general
is that it's built
to be interrupted.
And a lot of times,
the conversation
goes where the audience
wants you to go,
and thinking about how you
craft a narrative while actually
interacting with the audience.
It's used at multiple
different stages.
We know that faculty
are typically
asked to do it as part
of their job interview.
Along with a seminar, they
have to do a chalk talk.
A lot of trainees
don't know that.
But we've also seen
instances at multiple places
where some postdocs
are asked to do it
as part of their interview.
We know that graduate students
use it in their prequalifying
exams for many of our programs.
So we're training
them for something
that they'll see
in the second year.
And I've actually
heard of instances
now where graduate
students are being
interviewed for graduate
school using a chalk talk.
One of the things we found
working with our students
is we talk about
experimental design a lot,
that that's what you get
out of graduate school.
But we actually don't do
a lot of formal training
and experimental design.
That's a deficiency that we saw.
And we tried to address
that in our life sciences
graduate course by actually
trying to intervene, teach them
skills in experimental design,
teach them skills in science
communication, and then force
students to actually put that
into practice through the types
of assessments that we use.
So when we talk about
teaching experimental design
and how to do a chalk
talk, we do them together.
And we've developed a series
of resources including videos.
So we have sample questions
that we show students.
This is what the assessment
will look like in our course.
Then we have videos
that we've developed
a good version of what a
response would look like
and a great version of
what a response would
look like, and actually
put those on display
for the students along with
an annotated guide that tells
them, this is what a good,
this is what a great chalk
talk looks like,
and this is what
gets you to a high score using
a novel rubric that we've
developed.
So the students get sample
question, sample presentations,
and a rubric with an
annotated guide that tells you
how to excel at that rubric.
And the last piece that we're
finishing up with our project
is actually trying to
make animated movies
to explain this, so that
actually accompanies it too.
We're at the point
now, I think one
of the nice outcomes
from this whole project
is that we've lined up a
pretty robust set of papers
that we're developing as
outcomes from the project.
And we're actually
spanning back,
we're at a point where we're
analyzing data for 10 years.
And so this chalk
talk was actually
introduced in this class in
2009, the very first time
that it was done.
And then 2010, it was modified.
And we've gradually modified
it to the point where
it's been pretty consistent
for the last four years
what it looks like.
But the idea was simply we had
a standard molecular biology
class.
The person who was very
involved at the time
was Johanna Gutlerner.
She was a curriculum
fellow in the course.
She preceded me as
the curriculum fellow.
And I preceded Madhvi as
She thought we should
find a way working
with the faculty, the
faculty and the class
also, to make the
class more interactive
and actually to focus on
skills, which at the time,
was their idea for life sciences
graduate education, right?
Everybody said you
come to graduate school
to learn all the
mechanisms and the details.
And they were talking about
trying to introduce skills.
Fast forward 10 years,
now that's what everybody
is talking about in grad ed
that we need to focus on skills,
that it's not just an
undergraduate thing.
So it's taken on a life, I
think, a value in that respect.
So we worked it into the
course as an assessment.
And I think the
driving force behind it
was watching the
student feedback
on the course evaluations, which
told us that students liked it.
And what we learned was to
use the feedback in a way
to continuously address
the problems they
had with the
assessment to the point
where it's consistently
been one of the strongest
positives in the class.
One of the outcomes
from our project
is all the data analysis
we've done on course evals,
consistently positive.
And another thing
that we've seen
is when we ask students
years after they've
left the class, what
was the lasting learning
outcome from the course?
It's actually the
exercise and being
able to apply that skill in
multiple different settings.
Really enjoyed working
with the students.
And I think for me, they
weren't just workers.
They were also collaborators
in the project.
And I think it was really
important to involve them
in that way.
And I think also
just the breadth
of things we were able
to look at related
to experimental design chalk
talks and the different types
of outcomes, I think
that was really
valuable to have that breadth.
And I think that
the grant really
enabled us to have
a broader view of it
instead of just looking
at an individual part.
One of the things that's very
nice about the Spark grants
in particular is that when you
need a relatively robust amount
of money, but not an
immense amount of money,
like a NSF grant
or NAH grant, it's
enough money to get a good
amount of projects done
and get research done.
And it really helped with us
being able to engage students.
So this project really
benefited from the fact
that we have six students who
are helping with the project.
And I mean, one of the
projects literally entailed
transcribing 500 rubrics
for multiple years, right?
And two students did that.
And so that type of
work is not something
that it's really easy to
justify for a big grant.
But it's a starting point to
actually get the work done.
And what we've been able
to do is do that, right?
So a lot of that
engaging students
who have different expertise
like biostatisticians
to help us with analysis.
So I think the student
engagement part of it
actually has been a
really important outcome
of having the funding.